good afternoon everybody and thank you
for being here we're just so delighted
to see students faculty staff and
members of the community gathered here
to recognize Veterans Day several
faculty members who have served with us
are here today including veteran
emeritus professors who are sitting
toward the front and who we especially
honored today to all our current and
former servicemen and servicewomen who
are here with us today thank you you
have our deepest gratitude and respect
for over three centuries Yale students
faculty and alumni have chosen to lead
and serve in our nation's military
reminders of their sacrifices are all
around us in memorials such as the walls
just outside this very Hall or in the
Cenotaph out on the plaza but they're
also woven into the very fabric of our
society and our world in gratitude for
their service and leadership yel strives
to honor and support veterans we do this
through the Yale veterans Network a
campus group for students faculty and
staff and the Yale Veterans Association
an alumni organization tomorrow the Yale
Veterans Association will host in
partnership with the association of Yale
alumni and the Office of diversity and
inclusion an eight-hour training and
certification course on mental health
first aid
we thank the Veterans Association for
hosting and sponsoring them this is a
nationally recognized program under the
National Council of behavioral health
and it's designed for students faculty
and
staff yell also supports the warrior
scholar project a phenomenal program
founded by three yell gret graduates we
will hear from a co-founder jesse rising
yell chorus yell college class of 2011
in a few minutes
and we're proud of the many students who
currently serve in the Reserve Officers
Training Corps on our campus they're
sitting here with us today for their
service and sacrifice we must support
our veterans not only today on Veterans
Day but every day of the year
on a final note before I turn over the
podium yell as I said warmly embraces
its veterans and we are working hard to
reach out to every member of our
community who has served so employees
where veterans can help us with our
veterans count at Yale initiative by
logging on to work day to self-identify
as a veteran if you wish to do so this
is not required but it helps us to do
our best to give back to those who have
given so much to our country and our
campus so if you haven't done that
please consider logging on and
identifying yourself it's now my
pleasure to introduce Kim goth Cruz
yells secretary and vice president for
student life and she will say a few
words about today's program Thank You
Kim thank you all for being here today
Thank You president Salome good
afternoon everybody I am Kim Gough Cruz
and it is my privilege to be with here
with you here today as we celebrate and
honor our veterans throughout its
history Yale has been home to men and
women who have dedicated their lives to
the service of their countries we joined
together today to pay tribute to them
and also to reflect on the freedoms and
privileges that their sacrifices have
made possible for all of us we are
honored to have among us students
faculty staff and alumni who have served
and who are preparing to serve thank you
all for being here during our ceremony
you will hear from a staff member
current students and to Yale College
graduates each has served or contributed
to the well-being of veterans and each
is valued as a member of our Yale
community they represent commitment to
honor and country across multiple
generations and conflicts and they also
represent all of the veterans who are
here with us today and those who care
for them we are as a community
fortunate not only to have our treasured
veterans but also to have now firmly
established within the fabric of the
university culture the cadets and
Midshipmen of our Air Force and Navy
were ROTC programs the young women and
men in uniform are welcome and a common
sight on campus as they move between
classes labs laboratories their
residential colleges and of course their
military commitments I'm so happy to see
so many of them here today and I want to
give a special thanks to their leaders
especially our commanding officers Air
Force Colonel Tom McCarthy and Navy
captain Wayne grass deck for all the
work they're doing with our students to
help them make Yale and the ROTC better
in the last
in the last three years yell students
have actually increased their activities
around public awareness and advocacy for
our veterans and we are really grateful
for those efforts I just want to mention
a couple today that you should be
mindful of immediately following this
service the ceremony our LT wet students
are gonna lead a 30-minute walking tour
so make sure you have your coats there's
gonna be focused on yells military
history and it will include the Memorial
Hall the tour will leave from by Nikki
Plaza near the wall near Wall Street at
about 1:30 also yell students for
veterans are again creating this year a
field of flags on cross campus each flag
placed on the ground honors a veteran
who's important to someone in the yell
community so I invite you to visit the
installation write your the name of your
loved one on the flag and then have it
installed it's really a stunning display
for all of us to see and finally before
we move on I want to encourage and maybe
the challenge all of us to do something
special for our veterans when today has
passed and we return to our very busy
lives I hope and I challenge us all that
as we walk in front of the Alumni War
Memorial on Hewitt quadrangle or we move
through Memorial Hall and we see all the
names in the classes and the records of
service of our alumni who have given
their lives for us to be who we are as
an institution and who we are as
individuals that we will all take a
moment just a moment to remember the men
and women of Yale who have faithfully
taken an oath to protect and to serve
and with that is now my pleasure to call
upon the officers of the Yale University
Police Department who serve as our
collar color guard to come out please
stand if you are able and as they offer
the presentation of colors remain
standing followed by the playing of our
National Anthem
and then also remain standing for our
invocation
[Music]
let us pray
grand architect of the universe called
by many names in many languages by many
voices today we ask that your guiding
hands hold us and all our sisters and
brothers a military service near we are
grateful for all who now serve all who
have served and for those who in the
words of President Abraham Lincoln gave
the flesh full measure of devotion and
service of their country we are joined
in humility gratitude and our own
measure of devotion knowing that as we
seek to understand an increasingly
complex world we are sheltered by the
vigilant service of citizens to our
Republic we ask special regard for those
who have served but who have not yet
been found and returned home and for
those who have been returned but who
have yet to find themselves at home we
honor our military and ask that whatever
is required of them be informed by your
infinite wisdom as they honorably and
loyally seek to create a peaceful and
secure future for us all
first I would like to thank president
Sall of a secretary Gough Cruz and
others for holding this Veterans Day
ceremony and thank you to Dean Saudi for
recommending me to give these remarks I
would also like to thank the
distinguished guests in attendance and
all of you who are joining us here today
as a psychology major and student of
social science I'm keenly aware that my
presence at this university is a
statistical aberration I was born into
poverty to an immigrant mother
I spent my early childhood in foster
homes and later during the housing crash
of 2007 experienced the foreclosure of
the home of my adoptive family and as I
attempt to retrace my steps to
understand what gave rise to my current
fortunate circumstances two variables
stand out above all others military
service and generosity at age 17 right
after graduating high school I left my
two jobs as a dishwasher and grocery
clerk to serve my country to be
perfectly honest it was not a difficult
decision the military offered a path to
independence and gave me the chance to
prove myself
as an electronic warfare technician in
the Air Force I was charged with
maintaining defensive systems designed
to protect aircrew members in c-17 and
c5 aircraft from radar detection
heat-seeking missiles surface-to-air
missiles and other threats to this day
it amazes me that military would place
the lives of others in the hands of a
teenager yet this extraordinary trust
instilled me with confidence it calls to
mind a quote from the former Secretary
of State Henry L Stimson who once said
the only way to make a man trustworthy
is to trust him I worked with men and
women from all backgrounds along with
service members from other countries
including Qatar Germany and Iraq the
military had a place for me
perhaps ironically the stability of the
air force contrasted with the turbulence
of my upbringing I was a high performer
selected for early promotion and earned
numerous accolades for my service but
these external markers of accomplishment
were nothing compared to the realization
that I could rise above the
circumstances of my youth that I could
prove to myself and to others that
success is not limited only to those
born into fortune and circumstances in
short military service was absolutely
essential to helping me recognize my own
potential I used to think college wasn't
for me it was for other people for those
who were smarter or richer came from a
certain kind of background certainly not
for a poor foster kid yet here I stand
after matriculating to Yale I thought
that my life experiences both before and
throughout my service would add a unique
perspective to my college education and
this has been true but in addition it
turns out that my education at Yale has
also given me a unique perspective on my
military service for example and one of
my history classes I learned about the
progression of European militaries in
the 18th and 19th centuries from peasant
and mercenary armies to professional
militaries as this advancement occurred
the wealth and security of Europe
increased the combination of a more
prosperous society along with a
disciplined military led the bush huazi
to regard the military with derision and
even contempt for them soldiers were a
product of a bygone era relics of a
primitive age from which enlightened
individuals could escape it is difficult
not to occasionally observe parallel
sentiments in our society today another
lesson I've taken from my education here
is negativity bias our attention is more
easily captured by bad events this in my
view is one reason why it is important
to set aside special occasions to
remember the good it is tempting to
lament the flaws of the military or the
mistakes of this great country it is
easy to overlook this
sacrifices of our sisters and brothers
who have willingly taken up arms to
defend what is so easily taken for
granted I'm reminded of a conversation I
had with an elderly Polish gentleman
when I was stationed at Ramstein Air
Base in Germany some years ago as we
discussed travel politics in the US
military presence around the world the
elderly man said as you enjoy your visit
in any charming European city do not
assume that it's pleasantness is somehow
magically guaranteed to last some of
these states can go bad at a moment's
notice as history has shown time and
again if we're being honest the American
military has played a major role in
maintaining relative peace
in the world this brings me to my next
point
three months ago I discovered the secret
to happiness while I was employed as a
summer researcher at Stanford I met with
a professor named Albert bandura
professor bender is the most excited
living psychologist in the world near
the end of our conversation I asked the
distinguished 91 year old professor what
is the key to happiness and he actually
gave me the answer now I don't remember
what he said but it was really good in
fact he told me the key to happiness is
helping others generosity there is
nothing that can replace the feeling one
gets when one knows they have
contributed to the success of other
people pursuing happiness as a goal in
and of itself does not work it can only
come as a side effect of what we
psychology geeks call pro-social
behavior veterans take care of one
another for many of us it is not enough
to defend our country we seek other ways
to provide value the veterans at Yale
who came before me and contributed to my
path here the folks associated with both
the military and Yale understand albert
bandura's point for me this has
consisted of working as a mentor for
other veterans interested in higher
education and tutoring disadvantaged
schoolchildren at New Haven Reed's
moreover I research thought and behavior
at the Yale mind and development lab
ultimately I would like to apply the
tools for my education to help people
whatever their circumstances reach their
goals beyond service many veterans have
made it our duty to stand as examples
for others and if other people out there
learn of our stories and understand what
is possible perhaps they like me will
exceed their own expectations thank you
all and happy Veterans Day
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
when I was asked to introduce Jessie I
was delighted
Jessie rising is a graduate of Yale
College at Harvard Law School and is
currently serving as a federal
prosecutor in Chicago after a severe
injury sustained in the harvard-yale
game prevented him from commissioning as
a Marine Corps officer he founded the
Warriors scholar project to help prepare
veterans for academic success in the
liberal arts I first met him three and a
half years ago a few days after I left
the army I was attending the warrior
scholar project at Harvard before I
matriculated at the University of Oregon
in the fall the program he had developed
along with Chris Howell was meant to
teach critical reading and academic
writing through Tocqueville and
Thucydides but it was really so much
more my time there showed me that I was
academically capable of more than I'd
imagined and Jessie and Chris inspired
me to apply it to Yale as an Eli Whitney
student that next year if I hadn't
attended his program I truly believed
that I would not be standing here today
as a senior at Yale
[Applause]
thanks Jared for that kind introduction
I do have one bone to pick it's the Yale
Harvard game not the harvard-yale game
but other than that it's much
appreciated thanks Jared now I feel
especially humbled to receive this honor
here today because for me
Yale is where it all started I had no
intention to join the military before I
arrived at Yale but it didn't take me
long to realize that if a guy like me
could be plucked out of a hardscrabble
Midwestern town and given an opportunity
to attend Yale University then America
truly must be the land of opportunity I
learned about the foundations of
democracy and the brilliance of the
Federalist Papers at Yale but the moral
lessons were at least equally as
important as the academic ones the Yale
Creed for God for country and for Yale
resonated deeply with me I stood in awe
as I ran my fingers across the names
inscribed in the walls just outside the
doors of those who paid the ultimate
sacrifice and as I viewed the Cenotaph
on by Niki Plaza my knees buckled under
the weight of everything that those had
fought on our behalf had secured it was
Yale that compelled me to say send me I
need to do my part now ultimately as
Jared alluded to it was not part of the
plan for me to serve my country in the
military while tackling the running back
of that school in Cambridge that shall
remain unnamed I tore two nerves in my
neck which left parts of my right arm
and shoulder permanently paralyzed now
if I had to do it all over again I'd
give my entire arm for this place but
losing the Marine Corps as a result of
my injury
left in me a void that I relentlessly
try to fill every hour of every day
fortunately Yale equipped me to serve my
country in ways that could help fill
that void we ran our first warrior
scholar project academic boot camp here
at Yale in 2012 serving nine veterans
and we've now put over 700 veterans and
Counting through our academic boot camps
at more than 15 campuses across the
country during the warrior scholar
project veterans like Rob and Jared
wrestle with classical texts and engage
with some of the world's greatest minds
on themes of liberty equality and
democracy they realized that a deeper
love for one's country is achieved
through critical appreciation rather
than blind veneration and they realized
that here at home they can still live in
pursuit of the principles and ideals
that they put their lives on the line to
defend overseas the warrior scholars
like Jared and Rob they leave the
program not just ready to become great
students but prepared to live up to our
highest hopes and dreams for them to
become members of the next greatest
generation who remember not just for the
courage with which they fought but for
what they accomplished after they
returned home now I couldn't be more
grateful for the Yale Family which is
which has provided steadfast support for
our mission Yale family members Sam
Chauncey Nick Brady Charles Johnson
Glenn Greenberg Mary Beth and Peter
Oppenheimer were early believers in our
mission and their incredible support
continues through this day Yale
professors Norma Thompson and Marla
gajja John Gaddis Mike photos and many
others helped shape the minds of these
warrior scholars and my co-founder and
Yale classmate Chris Howell is one of
the most talented and dynamic people
with whom I've had the privilege
work and of course people like Jared and
Rob give us all hope for the future
thank you again for this honor
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen it is military
tradition to stand as I read the award
citation please join me attention to
orders citation to accompany the gold
Valor award to cadet Amanda e Lloyd
on 9 July 2017 cadet Amanda e Lloyd and
three friends we're at Lake Ontario
Beach when they heard screams for help
coming from five women and children in
rough water where the South Sandy Creek
enters the lake
cadet lloyd and her companions acted
quickly to organize a rescue attempt and
alert authorities to the danger in
response to hearing cries of we are
going to die from swimmers who were 200
yards off shore and struggling and ten
foot high waves strong current and
undertow cadet lloyd entered the water
with two lifejackets swimming to a
struggling young girl and taking her in
tow knowing her fellow rescuer had
entered the water without a life jacket
but unable to see him in the high waves
cadet Lloyd located him by calling his
name upon swimming to his location she
found him holding two additional young
girls using both lifejackets
cadet Lloyd and the other rescuer fought
against the undertow and brought the
three distressed swimmers to shore where
a third rescuer was waiting
cadet Lloyd and her companion re-entered
the water with the lifejackets swimming
to the two adult women several hundred
yards from shore
each rescuer took one adult in tow and
began to swim to shore joined by a third
rescuer in out they managed to get the
two to
women to safety five women and children
are alive today due to the quick and
selfless actions of cadet Lloyd by her
prompt actions and humanitarian regard
for her fellow human
cadet Lloyd has reflected great credit
upon herself in the United States Air
Force
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
let us pray eternal God we give thanks
for those who gave their lives in the
struggle for peace and justice
we are grateful that there are men and
women in our world who struggle for such
noble ideals and now we would dedicate
ourselves to ensure that their sacrifice
was not in vain as we struggle to make
our world a better place for all people
to live we beseech you to give us the
strength we need as we seek to fulfill
your will amen
well everybody that concludes our
ceremony for today thank you again so
much for coming and to all of our
speakers and congratulations again to
those of you who were tributes and
awards as well many thanks to the
planning committee and to our ceremony
participants as I said including Tom
Duffy and the Yale School of Music brass
band quartet
and again I just call your attention to
the other programs that will go on today
but again have a great day and thank you
for coming
[Music]